so i'm a huge gary vaynerchuk fan he's
one of the only
youtube channels that i watch pretty
much every single video that comes out
on his channel
he does a series called askgaryvee and
he answers questions from people
and on one of his recent responses
he kind of gave a douchebag answer and
so i wanted to make this video
my name is rafael i run the personal
development youtube channel
my question to you is what would you do
if you were starting over
and building your personal brand all
over again basically
getting the name garyvee out there all
over again in this day and age
what would you do to go out there and
really spread the word and to get
yourself
known i love this question and boy i'm
gonna set up do i have a really good
answer for this because
you and thanks for the question and
every other youngster
needs to hear this really really
loud and clear but i would do exactly
what i did
which is for the first 10 years of my
professional career
i didn't say a damn thing from 22 to 32
my friend i did nothing in building the
gary vaynerchuk brand you know what i
did
i did the work that allowed me to have
the audacity to build
the gary vaynerchuk brand this notion
that you can just come out the gate and
build your brand by growth hacking and
putting yourself out there
and getting on some podcasts and
leveraging other people's brands
to get on and build yourself as an
expert
in what and it's a douchebag answer
because
there's a lot of other ways to build a
personal brand and i want to give
rafael some real advice okay gary's
point
is you got to add value you want to
build a personal brand you need to add
value the stuff that you're creating
has to add value and what are you saying
is if you don't have a lot of experience
how can you add that value but the
personal experience is not the only way
to add value
let me give you two examples okay one is
model success
so when i first sold my company i was 22
years old i sold it for
seven figures it wasn't you know it's
not a billion dollar sale but it's still
seven figures
and when i was asked to go and speak
around the world to help other
entrepreneurs in developing and building
their businesses
what i talked about was modeling success
so i had a little bit of success with my
company
but what i shared mostly was mauling the
success of other people
so i looked at steve jobs and richard
branson and donald trump and how
they built their businesses and share
those lessons
because you can do the research and give
advice so if somebody is
for example trying to figure out how do
i name my company right that's their
question
you can say well here's how steve jobs
did it here's how
richard branson did it here's how donald
trump did it and you're not necessarily
saying here's how i think you should do
it
but you're giving advice from other
famous entrepreneurs you've done the
research and you're just sharing that
knowledge
okay so you're adding a lot of value
even though you don't have the 10 years
of track record
history and experience the other way you
can do it is to
interview people who know what they're
talking about who have that experience
you can go interview the guys like gary
vaynerchuk okay one of my favorite guys
who did this
and he fell off the map because of
personal illnesses but michael dunlop
became a rising star in the internet
marketing world and he was i don't know
19 years old 20 years old
and he knew that he knew nothing about
internet marketing and
what he started doing was going out and
interviewing all of the top guys in
internet marketing and asking
the dumb questions asking the startup
questions asking questions that
everybody has
asking the questions that he had as well
as the question that his audience would
have
and he had amazing podcasts that he
created
i don't know if you could still find it
it was on income diary go check it out
if you can find the early stuff
that michael dunlop put together and it
was great because
he got all of these experts on that were
previously inaccessible
nobody had interviewed all these people
at once together and every time
you went to his website you learn
something new something valuable from
a big expert and michael dunlop became
known as the guy who would go out and
interview these guys
and then he learned all these lessons he
was able to share so
if you don't have the knowledge base you
don't have the 10 years of experience
you still want to build a personal brand
don't just sit on your ass and just work
for 10 years
go and start sharing value share what
you have learned
share for modeling success and share by
interviewing people who have done it
that's how you build a real personal
brand
believe gary still love your stuff but i
think was a douchebag answer
if you want the real goods i share my
best advice for entrepreneurs every week
in my newsletter
click the link below to check it out
it's free